contrôle routier au péage d'auxerre nord
immobilisés sur le bas côté des bus
grandes distances en provenance ou à
destination de paris
cible prioritaire de la vingtaine de
gendarmes
les voyageurs en situation irrégulière
autrement dit les sans papiers une
opération d'envergure commandité par la
préfecture quand on parle de sécurité
des mobilités on parle également parmi
ces contrôles de la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière et on le voit
bien dans les contrôles qui sont menées
depuis ce matin nous avons d'ores et
déjà pu interpeller plusieurs étrangers
en situation irrégulière ce voyageur
escorté par les gendarmes auraient dû
quitter la france depuis six mois après
vérification il sera soit dirigée dans
un centre de rétention avant d'être
expulsé vers son pays d'origine soit
faute de place relâché dans la nature
débuté ce matin l'opération a aussi
mobilisé une quinzaine de policiers
comme ici à auxerre trois bus grandes
distances et une centaine de voyageurs
ayant été contrôlés dont deux étrangers
en situation irrégulière toute la
journée police et gendarmerie ont
inspecté les routes mais aussi les
trains et les gares du département la
logique de notre opération sécurité la
mobilité c'est que dans un temps donné
sur le département on puisse s'assurer
en fait du contrôle de tous les
mouvements et on vise évidemment les
délinquants les personnes recherchées et
puis aujourd'hui on a une focale
particulière aussi sur la police des
étrangers
ces contrôles qui ne disent pas leur nom
vise clairement à lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine
bilan des opérations du jour cette
personne en situation irrégulière
arrêtés dans l'yonne